[Music]  hi everybody i'm lauren zima we are here  at the big little lies any for your  consideration event I would play a  little game with the cats we're calling  it little little lies let's find out  just how truthful they are have you ever  lied to book a job of course if you tell  us what it was I probably said I could  do something I couldn't do like shoot  again in fact that I could I skate and I  couldn't so they got the bug in  breakdance and I said I could what  happened on set when you got them  convicted they fired me have you ever  lied to your significant other to like  get out of something you didn't want to  do of course  and that was I hate doing dishes okay  something like Oh way was terrible kind  of my finger can you do the dishes no I  can pretty much tell him when I don't  want to do I can straight talk on a  daily basis really yeah okay well what  was today's line on well I didn't like  today because I've been traveling all  day but I lie a lot